I have a dream that one day this nation
will rise up and live the true meaning
of its Creed
we found these truths to be self-evident
that all mankind was created we prefer
the term people kind not mankind all
right together we could create a unified
tomorrow one with little black boys and
little black girls some kids don't
identify as boy or girl you gender
conformist Nazi let me try this again
what about transgender people don't cuz
you don't want to understand you
transphobic piece of gender is spectrum
even know what a spectrum is yes it's
like this show me the size of your penis
that's assault to solve where are the
trigger warnings we got off on the wrong
foot let me try this again
I wish to see a day with transgender
children those who identify with gender
fluid gender bender drag kings and drag
queens by gender cross gender the gender
gifted to spirits gender fire and little
black boys and little black girls will
walk with the hands into the rocks
ask for consent he violated her hand
what Sam okay stand for Hitler literally
I hope that one day my children will be
recognized not for the color of their
skin but for the content of their
character unless your views for
different in mine then it's hate speech
I believe that one day Oh
the rough places will be made plain and
the crooked places will become straight
straight so you dislike gay people no
madam madam
don't you dare madam me don't you assume
my gender just because I have boobs like
a girl facial features of a girl doesn't
mean I'm a girl but literally says I am
a girl
patriarchy what is your gender I'm a
girl but it's wrong to assume you this
gendered bigoted yeah here's the
Gillette razor how about you shaved your
toxicity we must not be generating the
physical violence your words are
violence can you believe this guy Negro
will overcome did you just say the
n-word I have a dream what about people
with sleeping disorders oh so you have a
dream brother yes mom brother
I have ain't got no time for dreams cuz
I'm too busy being woke what you're not
gonna do is ignore the fact that
institutionalized racism is a real thing
my knee Gus see the white devil wants
your bacon but you're not gonna fry
today you can't see the kitchen because
your third eye is shut wake up wake up
it's breakfast time can you smell the
white demons sofa chips just would like
Jesus was black yeah Sammy - you
ungrateful sons a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] the patriarchy blacklivesmatter why
do you hate us I hate you
we don't hate you feminists hate the
patriarchy [ __ ] you cannot fight for
laws and last people by marginalizing
others watch me watch me your blackmail
blackmail your blackmail men are trash
now let's get to more important issues
it's consensual sex oppresses whoa this
is for the master race only your people
drink from over there all right
[Music]